ローさんの最近のシーズンインです
クローゼ薄い
名前はかんだというフローズンクローズ se 作られるチョコレートです
これ去年の去年の夏に発売したんですけどめっちゃ売れてますねっ
ねぇ
名
でね何がすごいかっていったら俺なんかただのアイスとかじゃなくて温めて食べるん
ですよ
500ワットの電事連時は60秒で1500あったの人なら20秒で
ぶっちゃってくださいじゃあ行きましょうん
はいというわけで温めたんですけどどうですかパッと見ちょっとおかしいと思うし何か
あって何でやって食べるのとか思うんですけど本当はお店で専用のストローをもらえる
んですけど
を亡くしましたので
うわぁねちょっと食べ過ぎたかおかしいぞこれ絶対強
遊びすぎたホット応じそうになるんですけどこれはちょっと
これついエアでもこんなんかな ship 作った和田も薄くッター
q 冷たいんですようけるんですけどチョコレートマンゴーがあってチョコレートの方
はちょっと高いんですよこれっていうのは
けど
深マンはの方が好きです
なんでマンガを紹介しないかといったら
さっきもあの我慢できずに伸びました
うんうんっ
チョコレートはこいつねすごいほんとチョコ底しててん
ちょこちょこっとしてるんですよ番号はね逆にこう
震えていいというかシャーベットっていうかすごい食べやすいんですけど
なんか
あとっていうチョコ好きな人はおすすめですけど
あまり何か甘いの嫌いんじゃお前の嫌いっていうか
なんか濃い味が嫌いな人はん
やめてくださいぜひねチョコレート好きでアイス好きって有効
マージナルマン的な人はこれですね
超この方選んでいただいて夫ねこーさやカーンと友好はなんか
この中でプレイシュナこうフレッシュな恋をフレッシュな好意したい人とかは
もう一つマンゴっていうのは置いてあるんだよ
ぜひねろーそんでー
貼ってみてください7